[Music]
we're going behind the scenes with Katy
Perry
Ricky's coming on this is just released
video from backstage during the UK's
most watched TV event of 2017 Ariana
Grande's one love Manchester trivial
nearly 11 million watched ariana
performed side to side but only Katie's
film crew captured Perry dancing to it
just off stage they also caught Katie's
in front - acapella and her reversing
part of me unplugged
Perry and her fellow performers raised
nearly three million alone during the
benefit nearly 13 million total the
superstars were clearly proud of a part
an important event saw severely doing
this year and backstage Ariana was
especially grateful
[Music]
[Applause]
Pini returned to the UK today tomorrow
she'll perform at the Glastonbury
Festival which today held a moment of
silence to honor those affected by the
recent terror attacks actor bradley
cooper also performed
next lady after this weekend she's going
to start rehearsals for her US tour that
kicks off in September
[Music]